hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're gonna be doing a
review on slow claps first game absolve
er so let's get started so too as a
summary absorbers an online melee action
game where you battle AI and then other
players are on the world using
hand-to-hand combat and is very painted
in pretty world the game is gonna be
priced at $30 with no season pass and
all future content is free just like
lawbreakers and titanfall I'm seeing a
lot of games do this now and I'm very
satisfied with that I'm sick of paying
$60 for a game and then doing the season
pass to get the other stuff although
it's not an issue I wish that games
would be more like this so that is a
very good positive thing about it
the story mode basically is your
character was handpicked to defeat
people known as the marked ones were
then after defeating all of them unlocks
a gate to defeat the final boss and no
spoilers even though kind of a little
bit did but the last fight was pretty
intense and exhilarating for me so it's
definitely worth getting to the end and
once you beat that it earns you the rank
of absolve er and the story mode is fun
and it keeps you on your toes a bit
especially during the boss fights but
the story mode is short and it took me
about five hours and it would have been
shorter if it didn't take years to find
the boss now it's not all the boss
fights but I swear some of these bosses
are harder to find than they are to
fight but absorber isn't a story game
and it's all really about fighting and
learning new moves to use on other
players the game is heavily focused on
PvP more than PvE once you beat the game
though you can do many other things like
farm for more gear you haven't found yet
or learn new moves you haven't acquired
which is super useful for when you're
playing in the combat trials which is
the PvP of this game you can learn new
moves and then use them in combination
with your old moves and make your combat
deck that fits your playstyle and
likeliness you can get these new moves
by blocking attacks or using your style
specific ability which is the dodge for
the windfall class which allows you to
dodge incoming attacks by either ducking
dashing jumping around and over those
attacks parry which is the Forsaken
class which is when successfully timed
opens the opponent to a free hit and
absorbed for the qalaat class which
allows you to resist damage when hit and
recover lost health of correctly timed
there is a fourth style in the game but
it hasn't been unlocked you have to be
level 30 and defeated named boss to get
unlocked it's basically drunken boxing
but I personally haven't unlocked it yet
I'm not I'm not at level 30 I'm very
close though as of the time I'm making
this so I'll try to get around to maybe
making a video over on the stagger style
I believe it's called but you can unlock
new moves in PvP and PvP as well if you
fight an opponent that you haven't
learned yet some of the other positives
of the game though is the awesome
customization the game offers yeah you
look like a hobo with a mask fighting
other hobos with masks but there's a lot
to customize like your top your
undershirt your pants masks shoes and
elbows that elbow and shoulder pads it
gives you a lot of diversity and a lot
of customization making for basically
everyone looking different instead of
all the same but do keep in mind though
all gear has stats and the more you put
on the slower your character is and you
could check that by looking at the
mobility stat in the bottom left though
but now that we're done with the
positives its kind of discussed some of
the negatives that have about this the
game so far has had multiple bug issues
like games crashing and in loading
screens and then just games crashing in
general the enemies being invisible even
though they can still hit you textures
of the map not loading in like this
example right here another negative of
observer though was the lack of content
at launch the game has a pretty short
story mode and as previously mentioned
as previously mentioned and the PvP only
has one game mode which is just your
standard 1v1 but the devs did say they
will add more game modes like a 3v3 mode
in the near future which sounds awesome
to me and the last negative is the
learning curve that the game requires
but it is there is a learning curve it
requires you the player to learn new
moves by continuously batting opponents
and taking new moves and making combos
out of your own but it is a fighting
game and most fighting games have their
own learning curve I mean for honor
hadded somewhat semi learning curve you
know Tekken and Street Fighter Mortal
Kombat and just this all of those have
different learning curves that you need
to adapt to and just get better at so
it's not a huge deal but it is still
there regarding the specs though I have
a shitty Lenovo laptop that I can run it
about 60 FPS so a medium settings on and
about 50 if you if I have OBS running
which is what it used to record this so
I do have a [ __ ] set up but it functions
very smoothly and I'm very happy about
that those basically all the negatives
though regarding the specs the there
wasn't much
about the negative aspects of the game
so I'm glad that there wasn't too many
but the bugs are a bit of an issue
hopefully they will fix that very soon
and that's basically gonna be my god for
absorber or my little review for absolve
err I hope you guys did enjoy that I I
displayed to you all the information and
then you do with that as you will will
you buy the game when you're not by the
game tell me the comments I'd really
love to know your thoughts on this it is
a very fun game a lot of people are
comparing it to Dark Souls and for honor
then kind of see the similarities Dark
Souls is a bit hard this game does
really not hold your hand at all this
game is a little bit like for honor with
the guard stances but there's a lot of
differences to this game and I'm very
glad about that it has its own unique
style you know with the the graphics
wise everything looks really great
the customization is great there's a lot
of things that are very unique about
this game that I do enjoy and the fact
that it's only made by about 20 to 30
people is pretty impressive to me so
anyway I displayed you all the
information do with it as you will if
you guys did like the video please sure
to slap a like on that like button it
really does help me out and tell me in
the comments I guess it below if you
guys do think that you might want to get
absolve er if you have it already if you
don't want it if you don't want it tell
me a reason why I'd really love to know
subscribe if you're new though form or
absolve or content as well as some for
honor content that I frequently post on
this channel as you can tell and either
way that's gonna be it guys I hope you
all did enjoy I'll see you all later
peace out